one thing I can't stand people like him
coming into my town and getting
recognized more than me I get it you got
a podcast you talk to famous people the
Border agent recognized me as we came
into Canada James's border agent stopped
him and I think that kind of
demonstrates pretty important difference
that I'm more of a man of the people
whereas James is kind of bit
inaccessible a bit kind of like cont
temptable love the podcast thank you
both of you both of you both of you both
of you I love the jiujitsu
cont
thank you now do you see there hat to
approach me first because he's just sort
of a bit like harsh with the public
aren't you whereas I'm like a I'm sort
of like a people's Champion I'm like the
rock I need to get back on Tik
Tok that couldn't have been more perfect